Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent.
And so here it is gene.
It's show time.
The business has done.
Let's get into it with the realness.
You Ready?
Yeah,
let's get this show started.
Okay.
Yeah.
Today I'm going to be a doctor.
So I am doctor Mel.
You can call me Doctor Mel.
And today we are going to talk about ways to tell her pussy stinks.
Hmm.
Oh is Randy.
Don't bring anyone in loving.
Well
go to your mom's house
and
Christina,
it's interesting.
Okay.
I
have
aids minor right now.
Why did you turn away to blow your nose from the microphone?
You when you know the audience likes to hear it.
I don't know.
It's just habit and we're polite guy.
You're not polite.
I am polite.
You don't look,
they loved it.
When I sneezed it became a wide sensation.
I would sneeze,
but I didn't have a sneeze.
You brought home aides from Nebraska.
Oh Man.
And I shoot a special this week.
Hi.
It's the worst possible time.
I,
um,
yeah,
I went to the doctor that I just said like,
look man,
normally I would just ride this out and he says a cold or something,
but I can't risk anything.
So he just like,
we'll just give you fucking high dosage.
Everything.
Don't get three.
Told me they'll risk it.
Don't text while driving.
You can't do that.
So we'll see you,
man.
I hope I make it through it.
You,
I know you will.
And here's why,
right?
You're strong.
You've also got many days to go in the week,
so you'll,
you'll hopefully,
you'll be strong by the time you have to tape and you know something else.
You're a pro.
You've been doing this for a million years,
you know you've done it,
you've done standup sick now that you want to,
it's terrible.
But you know what?
You'll get an adrenaline push.
You know what happens?
Like you can perform with a fever of like 102 and diarrhea because your body
shuts it down.
I booked a car to drive me for that show tomorrow just because,
yeah,
I was like,
I'm trying to get,
you know what I mean?
Like just want to relax in the car.
Yeah.
Not Be stressed about.
It just poses a stink and people want to know what's going on.
I can tell you,
I can tell you how bad was his mouth.
I don't because I want to talk about pain but I don't,
and I'm talking to him about what guys I've been telling me,
they'd been like,
oh my God,
fuck this bitch pussy smell so bad
Melanie.
Wow.
Dr Mill after.
So I fuck this bitch.
Yeah.
Jeez.
Take her to a cab
by herself and make her tell her how about your truck?
If she says no,
she say I can't talk because everybody came and then when she 12th that's a way
cause you know she'd be moving the booty and then video opens up,
opens up,
opens up and then the smells.
This like comes out.
So
I think she has a lot of experience actually validate Dr Melanie.
Well,
how would you know how to identify a stinky beef?
Unless you have one.
Well,
I don't know.
I wouldn't accuse Melanie of doctor,
excuse me,
Dr Melanie of having one and where are you credentialed Dr. Bell that she is
giving you ways to figure it out,
which I appreciate.
I can tell you some other ways.
Oh,
stick your finger in there.
No.
Does she wear patrolling and that's,
I'd rather you pussies smell like a fucking sewer in New Orleans the day after
Mardi gras.
Then smell Pachulia oil.
Well that's why they put it on their masks.
Other smells Pachulia I'm convinced that that's the smell of dirty box that's
made from dirty vagina.
It's disgusting.
If she says no,
you already know.
Okay,
stinky because he is,
she said and she does it.
Then you can try smelling already cause you know the,
the booty cheeks opening.
It's like I can't twerk to say my eyes for the bad smell of the visit.
Right.
I'd say another way you can tell is everybody at burning man as a stinky pussy.
Yeah.
They're not showering for a week and they're on that Playa and it's hot and all
they do is hose people down.
There's no showers.
White girls with dreads.
Yeah.
I'll try.
If you have dreadlocks,
it stinks down there too.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean if you're white,
if you're white and you had dreadlocks,
definitely I'm going to go and say a lot of leather,
the leather wristbands and yeah,
let me get your box stinks and,
well,
leather pants aren't very poorest either.
Oh,
I'm going to go with leather pants.
I am going to go and,
and this is,
this is going to be a hot debate.
Um,
women in Birkenstocks.
Yeah.
You can tell by shoe wear footwear.
He looked down if they have like dirty feet.
No,
I don't know if the Birkenstocks really equal that,
but I do think how you take care of the rest of your body is indicative of how
you take care of that.
Yeah.
I don't think it's true.
Sit down.
I think,
um,
if you guys are comfortable enough and you already go to a house,
go smell her auntie dirty dirty underwear.
I know it sounds kind of gross,
but I am telling you that.
Yeah,
you should take a chance and go smell it.
What do you think?
And she's the the vagina detective?
Yeah.
Do you think,
I mean,
I guess you could tell right by smelling her underwear.
if we're going to go through the trouble of having her twerk and then finding
her dirty undies and sniffing him,
why not just hook up with her and find out?
Just eat that sneaker.
You could put a digit down there and sniff your digit.
I mean,
isn't that,
I got a train.
Yeah.
I don't know what's,
what are you?
What have you been doing historically?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't care.
Yeah.
I don't care if it's my work together Trashcan,
I don't care.
Okay.
I have a,
she's,
I remember encountering one that was not in ware county.
No,
I encountered one.
Oh,
not like the most pristine
whatever.
Didn't bother me.
Okay.
Let me know.
I wasn't eating fucking meals down there,
you know?
All right.
Yeah.
You're just,
you shove it in and then you're done.
I don't know.
I think all this stuff about stinky,
this and that,
it's like,
you know what,
we're all people.
It's just some days you nasty sown days,
you ain't,
I've smelled my own balls wherever.
Like Jesus,
man,
that smells horrific.
Right?
I mean,
don't you feel like there,
it's just hot and some good days and bad days.
Bad days for sure.
That the area between your thigh and the bottom of the bag,
you can put your thumb down there like this.
Yeah.
Was Nasty.
Not on everyday,
but there's some days where you're like,
that is foul.
Yeah.
I think it's interesting that there's so much focus on stinky vaginas,
but stinky balls or another problem to real issue or acting like a,
it's another thing that's dividing our nation.
There's cat people are dog people still give vagina is a stinky malls.
Yeah.
No one is talking about those stinky balls.
No,
sorry.
But it's a woman's problem.
It's silly.
It's a real issue.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean like it's just all,
it's all body parts.
Who Cares?
Right.
Let's see,
uh,
her other,
her other insight.
Let's check that doctor mouth.
Sure.
If a gun is always crossing our legs,
you know she has this thing keep busy because why not?
His hands crossed.
It's not comfortable.
I know they're talking about,
oh,
it's lady luck.
It's not comfortable to have your legs crossed at all time.
So even though I'm not a lady,
I'm telling the truth.
Nobody wants to cross them all the time on neither one with smelly Boosie.
Yeah,
I do love her accent and I could watch her all day.
I like watching her.
Yeah,
she's really pretty.
She was as second language though.
Bahamian?
No,
I mean your Mama's.
Yeah.
Why?
By hate my Bahamas.
It's not that accent or like she's an island island or hummus.
Okay,
but you said it like I know the island.
Aren't you the master of accents?
You tell me master.
I thought she struggled just enough where it would imply that maybe English as a
second line.
That's what I thought.
Who knows,
you know?
All right.
Sounds like a certain patois.
All the girls you see with those crazy,
but then they have like the sweating from the pussy.
What do you expect smells like?
Why are you sweating?
I mean,
I understand it skiing and stuff,
but you know you swept,
most people stink.
So if you switched from the policy.
Yeah,
good theories.
This is an interesting theory.
She also says you can do this.
I didn't know.
She was like pretty aggressive.
It's are you in the car and you're driving
30 minutes,
you guys get to your destination.
She gets out,
I cake closer to off for like five minutes.
They come back out and be like,
oh,
I forgot something in the car,
go to the car and smell the seat of smell the car.
If the call smell is different.
That what you used to,
you know that's her and you know that most likely a vagina.
Hmm.
So interesting.
She has more suggestions.
More.
There's more than this.
When she's really obsessed with these stinky vagina.
Somebody,
some,
someone gone her head,
somebody said it to her once,
but then again days the regular mode if you want to take your chance or
whatever,
well why you mess around?
I know you all do that already so I don't really need to tell you,
but your finger her and then there's now anyway,
some people don't mind or where they still take the El and be like,
okay.
He was thinking but I was too deep in it to do it because I know a lot who do
that.
Yeah.
Maybe or Ivory Coast or something.
Could be,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm throwing it out there.
The Turks and Caicos.
Yeah.
I'm saying maybe like Haitian could be you.
That'd be a good guy.
I hear,
I hear more of a Patois than uh,
an actual like ESL thing happening.
Okay.
Maybe I'm Jamaican.
No.
Okay.
I'm going to go with Haitian because she's like light skin and she's got the
blue eyes are Bahamian.
Where's it?
Okay.
I know.
Where's,
where's Rehana from?
Barbados.
She's from Barbados.
She looks like she's got,
Rihanna is a coloring and stuff.
Not just stop guessing.
Never guess again.
That should be the name of your new album.
Can never guess.
Never talk.
Stop talking.
This is kind of exciting.
One of the things we play on here quite often is,
you know,
when,
when great audio comes into our life.
So,
um,
let me see if I can,
this is,
this was such a big hit on our show and we assumed it was gone,
uh,
that it would never enter our life again.
Are we doing it?
We're doing it.
I'm so excited.
And so just tell us how it happened.
Your phone was off.
My God,
no,
no.
My phone went home was silence and I don't,
I don't usually accept phone calls after a certain time.
We put our son down and it's time for me to relax.
Yeah.
I never,
I normally don't even look at the phone and I got a voicemail from a strange
number I didn't recognize.
I transcribe it,
I like to look and it couldn't transcribe it.
I hit play.
Should I just play it?
And this is what I heard.
Hello May in companies here,
Marge,
in your mind,
I'm writing my name,
Jaxon White,
improper.
You don't have on my gym located,
we'll call.
They get trained my day and I'm yelling Jello,
which was how the time they will do
any good days at Ted.
Why do you just have to locate it?
You know,
you have to go through and then Zammino me.
I think what you see if he'd been the z equals Rad.
The good.
Right.
The last mission when please call me to get someone's information.
Ma'Am.
That's my Kansas.
So the call me,
no know I get into his house.
He lived me or is it,
so for those that don't know,
we're over a year,
this woman has been leaving messages for silo may uh,
this Persian woman has been leaving messages for Sala May on Christina's phone
that cause she got a new number about a year and change ago.
Yeah.
And there's always aggressive cursing Farsi and some broken English.
Every time people write in our,
our,
our Farsi speaking listeners translate for us.
Yeah.
But she had been gone for so long.
We assumed
my months.
I mean,
I know the last sal,
I know the last we heard that there were squirrels in the trees and she's
putting plastic bags in the trees to get rid of the squirrels and it worked.
And that was I think when we moved here.
So that was awesome.
Hello.
May
I want to know what that Farsi ladies did?
He get on pictures and all of that.
The most amazing these messages that Christina keeps getting nonstop on her
phone to me or the person who's leaving never hears back from whoever.
She's kind of whoever you're contacting.
How about you?
Just so you guys aren't friends,
there's no love there.
Crazy.
Then you'd sexted for thank God you said sounds good
man.
Sounds
that's Brian days.
Such a good sign.
And I thought we'd never hear from the silo may thing again.
Now if you hear,
I don't,
I don't speak Farsi,
but she does say an English.
I lost my phone.
Yeah.
Now that could be a key component here and why we haven't heard from her in so
long.
Could be,
but I'm glad she's back.
She has your number.
Same season.
She wrote that one down.
She has it in her old,
uh,
contact book that they read,
put into her new iPhone or whatever.
Yeah.
So anyone speaking Farsi,
if you could translate that one,
let us know what's up with her and if she says her name,
who are you?
She never says her name.
I don't know what to call her.
Yeah,
it's really crazy.
But it brought so much joy back into my heart knowing that the sour me ladies
back in town,
it's a lot.
I was actually just thinking about her a week prior,
like,
Oh,
I wish I could get other voicemail from Salamay lady.
It's been so long.
I know.
We just thought we figured it was gone.
Yeah.
I mean,
you had every,
we all had good reason to believe it was going.
Yeah,
it's been,
it's been since we moved here in November,
she was,
uh,
leaving messages to cover your lemon.
You're your citrus.
And in plastic bags.
We got it that one time that just fell out.
Yeah,
I know.
Because the squirrels were eating the citrus and if you cover it in the bags,
they don't,
they don't need it.
Yeah.
So silly.
Um,
yeah.
So do you want to maybe as a time,
I mean the camp.
Yeah,
do it.
Let's hit it.
I want all the sound effects.
I want chips and ball.
I want a cat eating kibble and I want a brand new sound effect for this
announcement.
Okay.
This is a huge announcement.
Here we go.
We'll get that explosions
sound effect.
Your why now that usually means
big announcement chips in a bowl.
It's a big investment.
That's a cat eating kibble.
That's right.
That's my ads off.
It's the cutest sound.
It's such a cute sound.
That means even bigger.
Even bigger.
Yes.
Now we go through the regular big announced,
right
and now to cap it off to make it even the biggest of all announcements.
A new sound effect.
Okay.
The utensils against glass.
This must be major news.
Major News.
It is Tom.
It is
share with you all.
Last year,
you know,
I came out as bisexual and this year I'm proud to announce falling by.
But on a real note,
you guys remember I taped my standup special law in June and meet rattle and I
am proud to announce,
I am proud to announce that it will debut on Netflix.
Strike guys,
get it ready.
Put It,
put it on your list.
October 10th.
Cue it up.
Christina p mother inferior is the name of the special and you can search for it
starting this Friday and you can put it in your queue and your list of stuff you
want to watch and it debuts on the 10th of October and you can watch it.
Long time coming.
Jean,
longtime listener,
first time caller.
I'm very excited.
It's been a road and I'm so,
I'm so excited for you guys to see it.
And uh,
this was filmed in front of mommies and this was a mommy exclusive
for the moms.
And just so you know,
there's a lot of shout outs but there are shout outs in my special to your mom's
house listening.
So it's a tribute to the Mommy's,
if you will.
It's really exciting.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait.
I couldn't be happier.
And I called it mother inferior also as a shout out to the mommies mom's house.
Super.
Your mom's house centric.
Yes.
It's a really great hour.
I watched it live.
You bring me up and that's your voice.
You'll hear it in the opening of the special time I left.
I left it in that.
You're my gene is bringing me up.
That's how special that was.
October 10th.
You guys get ready.
Get ready.
I can't motherfucking wait.
I can't wait either.
So excited.
So amazed.
Are we going to watch it every night before we go to bed together in our
rotation of my standup specials?
Well,
that's what I do every night.
I watch mostly stories.
Completely normal.
Goodnight.
And then I kiss you goodnight.
And they
the dogs.
Yeah.
I even have a little video of things I put on Youtube and I watch all of those
of yourself myself.
Oh,
could you man,
I'm sure there are people that do that.
There's definitely people that do that.
That's crazy.
100% people that do that.
Um,
speaking of Patois there,
this is a real Jamaican guy and he's blown away that an Asian man is in his
store and speaks Patois.
It was pretty funny.
No,
what?
Yeah,
and
10 among come pick up your money.
What kind of [inaudible] what?
We did have enough customer for beer.
It's a China mine call Matt.
Tell him what my rotted,
hold on one more time.
Montana one
didn't want to
come in.
You do you want I want the money.
The money.
No,
you get me.
That is weird,
right?
It's like faces to put an accent on it.
You just go like,
that doesn't add up.
Why don't,
I mean,
I don't know about you,
but I'm pretty open minded and I don't feel weird.
Do you feel weird?
Like what do you,
what do you think you normally you should here?
Uh,
just different stuff.
I mean,
I know,
but it's true.
Like when you see whatever you see,
like gingers in speaking Spanish,
I always am like,
oh,
that's an interesting,
like you just don't assume that a ginger speak just because they're red hair
makes them not intelligent or,
no,
no.
Just that,
like the language isn't usually associated with the way they look.
No,
I know.
I'm just kidding.
It's like an Irish person speaking Chinese.
You're like,
wait,
what?
Yeah.
Like Canelo Alvarez,
the boxer,
he's this redhead white guy and you know,
he's Mexican so he speaks just Spanish.
His English is terrible.
And when I would study abroad,
like I remember there was,
you know,
there's redheads and you're like,
you speak Spanish.
And they're like,
yeah,
I was born here.
And you're like,
oh yeah,
you guys are everywhere.
Remember that time we saw that white guy totally spit in Chinese.
That's the,
that's the most crazy.
That's the wildest of all white people are fluid in any Asian language.
And it usually by the way,
blows Asian peoples mind.
Like that's like when my sister spoke mandarin at that dinner.
Do you remember that?
I was like,
yeah.
He was like,
it's so hard.
It's so hard.
It is.
Yeah.
Well it's such a foreign tongue.
Like I think that's what so bizarre.
Like I've never seen a white person speak.
Um,
you know,
Hindi have,
I mean,
of course,
of course it exists,
but you just don't,
you don't see what I've ever been in a museum probably in Paris.
And they're,
you know,
they had the tour groups and there was a Japanese tour group led by a white
woman and she was stopping at every painting with this Japanese group just
ripping through Japanese,
you know,
with all the little mannerism.
Sorry,
Todd Monet.
I'm an IB and they were all like,
oh,
I see who do,
I still don't know why
that sounded good.
Oh,
so you calling from me?
Yeah,
we come from,
we come from Vietnam,
Vietnam
in Vietnam.
So I to be good butter because a lot of me friend from pat too,
and I have house in Barbados and I lost him my damn money.
Hmm.
See that's how you do it,
man.
Barbado see so Barbados,
they talk this way too.
It goes back.
Dr Melanie.
Yeah.
Assumptions.
You love black girls.
Menominee not like big buddy.
Yeah.
Mon Sometime.
Yeah,
he took,
he hesitated.
He had the nerve to hesitate on that question.
What happened was he was honest in that question.
Yeah.
You said a lot.
He's like,
yeah,
black girl.
He was like,
ah,
I can tolerate it.
Yeah,
but you live in Joe.
You should love black girls should go back to hell.
That he should have been like,
fuck.
Yeah.
I love core.
That's what I'm saying.
Stupid.
Stupid is so stupid.
Huh?
Go back to Saigon.
A motherfucker right here.
Thank you denning.
Mother fucker.
Shit.
Yes.
You ain't shit.
Um,
speaking of coming hard,
oh my God.
Nobody said that.
We didn't say that.
You know what I'm talking about.
You know what I mean?
Wow.
You know what we found?
We found oh,
early footage.
Oh yeah.
No early funding.
No,
no,
no.
Do you want to see his early footage?
No,
it's pretty cool.
Please don't.
Sorry.
Your kidney and gradually feel the gin in the kidney chain into cheap.
Okay.
And sued the kidney.
Have a connection down to the testicle.
He has been.
Oh Gee.
In his day for 40 years.
Giving instructions.
What did I tell you?
My theory?
Was He just a pervert?
He's been talking about his balls since the 70s it's evidenced here and he wants
to talk about his cock and balls all day and make a living at it and now he does
good
for him.
I went,
Lady,
when you reverse few,
your nepo connect to the back here.
It doesn't connect to the band after that from the back,
make a lie.
Dot.
Through the kidney.
The kidney for why I'm sad.
Must add the kid man,
when you finish the kidney massada testicle,
testicle in crowd about factory producing a lot of sexual energy.
Okay.
And the biggest west in the human is the declaration demo.
No,
boy.
Yeah,
he was a perv since then.
He's always like,
play with your nuts.
Yeah.
Play with your dad and Jack.
You're digging.
Yeah.
50 Times a day and then you'll be better.
It especially if you're not circumstances,
you got to do this even more.
That's true.
Now that I hear him speaking back then he should know.
He should know circumcision by now.
It's an old school.
I don't say it's been 30 years.
He should know circumstance like I thought he just dances.
Yeah.
He's like you.
You're not circumstances.
You don't mind.
You cannot.
You don't know how to Tom Farm.
Yep.
TESCO's is Christ.
Oh,
he's just
a monkey.
Yes.
Few sounded like chanting inside you.
It's really something on term at home.
You know you do.
And sometimes we can watch TV and do that.
Yeah.
He's been a pervert his whole life.
What did I tell you?
What supports my theory that he's been a jerk his whole life doing this stuff.
Embarrassing himself and making audiences uncomfortable.
And now look
and hold a hold a hold testicle and massage the lower domino.
So Cu Ba,
the gym 10 into t man Massat 36 times
and reverse that cowed the clock.
Why 36 so he,
he upped it.
Of course it took that long.
Yeah.
He's built a tolerance.
No,
your Nicole.
Yeah.
He's been jerking his dick forever,
man.
Dude,
that's crazy.
My theories,
right.
I knew it.
He's just been a pervert since the beginning.
Rob,
rob is he,
and then it turned into that it started with just massage or texts testicle and
now 50 50 50 he nasty.
Pull the glans penis.
Yeah,
he's got,
he always looked to do is just nuts all day,
Matt.
Yeah.
It's so silly.
That's all he wants to do in nasty.
This is hell.
You think he's married?
Whose Mrs?
Rub Rub.
I think he's been married.
Yeah,
I think he's done.
Been married and then I think he's been through a few.
She caught him sharpening his knife a few,
many too many times.
He's like,
are you,
are we ever going to do it?
He's like,
wow.
Sharpening my name.
Right.
His shop.
Yeah.
I think he's been dropping that,
that load everywhere.
Do you think he's just really,
he really is just into sharpening his own.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Then sexual energy and yeah,
it's the morning guy.
I think he just wants it all the time.
It's so gross.
Would you kiss him?
No.
Wa like a nice soft skills.
Why?
Bam.
Stop Kissing him.
What'd you,
what'd you make out with him?
What'd you kiss?
Kisses.
Rob rubs.
I don't think it'd be very nice.
What'd you rather makes?
We love to him.
Eighties.
Rob.
Rob Or present day.
Rob broke.
Die.
Um,
think about it.
I want you to think about it because I think present day,
I think president,
he's just so much more experienced,
but it's like musicians where you're like,
I like their early stuff cause they're so,
no.
I like,
I like them.
No,
you like the technique refined.
He would know so much.
He would just school me now back then he'd be like me your balls.
But we already do it 36 times already do that.
There's nothing new.
But now he'd be like,
pull that circumstances back from,
let me do it.
Really for him.
He guys are gross.
Can I say what happened yesterday?
You were in bed sick and I went out to the front yard and I found a dead rat.
You did.
Now we've been laying out rat traps to catch these assholes that had been
shitting in my kitchen.
Tell you guys about it.
Yeah,
I mean look,
they can live outside.
That's fine.
But then when you come into my house you shit.
Yeah,
my floor.
It's a problem.
I said fuck you.
Right?
Yeah.
You said you'd sit hub or wearing the same shit I got on.
You know what the key was though.
We set out all these traps and everything.
The guy that came over to her house showed me that under,
under a sink in the kitchen,
uh,
where the pipe comes in.
I might've already said this,
but if I didn't,
there's like where the pipe comes in.
There's also a space time hype meets the wall and it's bigger than the space
needed for the pipe to fit through the wall.
So I got the insulation foam.
Yup.
And sprayed it in there.
There's no weight.
And we never saw them again after that rat lock.
And,
uh,
and just so you know,
rats,
the guy showed us,
he goes,
they need an opening this big,
and I'm holding on my finger.
It's maybe the size of a dime.
No,
no,
sorry.
Nickel and nickel.
And as long as their head can get through the whole,
he said they can squish their shitty little bodies into your house.
So when you think about it,
they find an opening,
not very big,
not hard to do.
So these assholes come in your house and they poop all over.
Your stuff is so nasty.
So when I found that out yesterday,
so I was thrilled and I put on some latex gloves and I double bagged it and you
know,
but I was,
I was surprised actually it how happy I was to catch a dead rat.
I was,
you were talking about it a lot.
A lot.
I took a photo,
I sent it to you.
I texted it to the guy that helped us set the rat traps outside and I kind of
got worried because I was like,
the only thing that could have made me happier is if we set up hidden cameras
and I can watch it die.
Listen to yourself.
I know.
I worry because I was really thrilled because I feel like he did us wrong.
Who's the psycho killer and this now I thought it was me.
I know a little bit of it is,
I'm a little worried at how thrilled I was to find it dead.
Well just cause it's a threat to my,
my young,
a threat to my home,
to the cleanliness of her house.
I just,
it's so the only people pooping our house should be cigarettes.
Period.
You little jeans and me.
Three people who poop under this roof.
That's it.
I think guests,
guests there a lot of posts and the nanny to come over.
The plumber.
Plumber took a lot of leeway on that.
Yeah.
Let me get electricians.
Gene,
we're going to take a dump in here.
I can't believe you.
Briars nasty morning down to our house.
What a jerk jerk.
I was like nine to come on now.
You shouldn't take that shit.
Think anyway,
that happened.
And then um,
the other last week we were having breakfast and as we do and we have our coffee
and then we eat breakfast and you had to take a dump in the middle of breakfast.
Like you felt the tug,
like you had to go.
And what I think is interesting about you is that when you feel the need to
shit,
you keep eating,
you eat through the pain of having to take a shit depends.
Depends on how good the meal looks and how bad I have to shit.
If it's a mediocre meal,
I'll be like,
I'll just shit later.
But if it's like,
wow,
if I go like this is going to be an awesome meal,
you know,
then I'll go,
shit now.
No,
you mean if it's a weight,
if it's an awesome meal,
you'll go shit now and then come back and eat it cold.
No,
I'm saying like if I walk into a place and I order food and then they're like,
food's on the way.
Oh,
I have to take his shit and I'm like,
this is going to be an amazing meal.
I'll go clear the chamber to really enjoy the meal.
Oh No.
I'm talking about the foods already in front of you.
We're in the process of eating.
This happened last week.
I got to take a shit.
Yeah,
we were eating already.
How urgently though?
There's so many levels.
But for me,
for instance,
I know like,
Hey,
I have to go,
the need to go is kind of not making this meal enjoyable,
so I'm gonna get up,
go take it down.
Come back,
eat my food cold,
but at least at least I don't have to shit.
No,
I don't think like that.
I see you walk me through your logic because I,
I just don't think,
I don't,
can't sit there and then eat and feel like I used to love those.
Like I could take a shit and I have to shit.
Those are different.
Cut and have to take a shit right now.
I got to eat this right now,
but if like if I go have to shit right now,
I'm still go.
Just depends,
you know?
So you're telling me it's just,
it's just the level of severity.
Yeah.
How,
how severe and again,
how good this meal's going to be.
If it's like really enjoyable.
I'd rather not have that feeling of having to share.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Should we,
they,
we should pause to think our guests going to be here any moment.
Tress pause.
Let's press pause and then he does.
Yeah.
That's a great thing to bring up when he gets here.
We back very soon and we're back with big,
dumb,
goofy retard cheeks,
cheeks,
so intense.
I love him.
I love under the weather.
So we're here under the weather.
We're here with,
uh,
you'll you don't even know.
Oh my God.
Don't even tell her.
So you know,
fighters have nicknames,
right?
So it's like Iron Mike Tyson.
Do you know what his nickname is as a fighter,
Brendan?
The genes?
Nope.
This is so exciting.
I cannot tell you how exciting.
So it just hit me.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Tell her your nickname as a fighter.
Big Brown.
I think I saw somebody write that.
Yeah,
I got it from Brian.
It's because he took like that biggest shits
and all of the US ever.
That's mean Cain Velasquez.
We have to battle over that name.
So did you guys,
when you're,
cause there all these stories about like,
I don't know if you've ever,
when when Phelps Michael Phelps was training that he was eating like 12,000
calories a day.
Did you have like heavy intake when you're training or no.
Like did you eat calorically a lot?
No,
not really.
I've never been that like a huge eater.
I,
I'd say I'm more in tuned with my diet now that I retired,
that I'm in show business then when I was fighting,
because again,
when you're fighting you can kind of eat whatever you want because you're going
to burn it off.
That's what they say.
No but isn't that crazy like shredded.
But I was like,
no I worked out nonstop but I wasn't like you know the biggest thing for that,
if if you follow football you think about like those two days and then you're
like,
wait,
how are guys still fat?
You know?
Because like I'm serious.
Like you would go,
you think about like how much you're moving and burning in,
in like in like a summer camp for five weeks.
It's only five weeks ago.
I can't do that.
It's like normal shit.
And then also like I stay so fast it's genetics that's,
that's big part of eating but don't eat so much.
Cause I used to do Kung Fu in the park when I was 28 years old and I would burn
so many calories but then I'd go eat a bean and cheese burrito and two talks and
then I was still fucking fat.
My mentality has always been like I would do like an hour workout with a trainer
and then be like,
I guess I could eat like 15,000 then I'm good.
Good.
Sometimes you are sometimes you over this but I would,
I've not been so I've never been so self conscious of my diet tool.
I started doing comedy like,
like really,
you know,
whenever I'm comes from when I'm backstage,
yeah.
I usually like spread my legs so I'm not as tall.
I'm usually super self conscious of what I wear because I don't want to look
that big.
Oh I see.
That's interesting.
Do you feel you feel,
you really think about what you're wearing all flat in the,
in terms of what the,
that you don't want to appear like the uh,
too much of like a stud.
You,
well you don't want to appear too big.
Like,
I'm not going to go on there with like a under Armour tight compress shirt.
Yeah.
That's not cool.
Right?
Yeah.
That's super lame.
It's also like,
it's funny with comedy,
if you have a physical attribute that is like a blessing,
you almost want to disguise it.
Like super muscular guys shouldn't try to show the muscles and super attractive
girls like I'm sure you dress it down,
right.
Not going to have your titties out or you're asking and I have huge tits,
like huge tits.
I would never guess that's right.
No,
there,
there.
You know that I'm fucking like quadrupled above a quadruple,
like F.
I'm not exaggerating.
Damn good.
Nobody would know it because I have and Phyllis Diller to had huge tits.
You know that big bits.
Yeah.
Gold sequins.
Tina do stand up.
Thank you.
My mother in law,
but I've had women in the past.
Tell me,
you should show him off and I'm like,
no one's going to listen to me.
Probably is distracting.
Exactly.
It's going to take away from your actual talent,
right?
Yes.
I agree.
Long legs with heels and stuff.
You're like,
people aren't listening to what you're saying.
They're looking at your finger,
not going to take you serious and they're going to be like,
is your Vagina Sankey?
They might like you know,
well for,
and also when I first started doing it,
I think Rogan's is and tell me that she's like,
you don't want to show your tattoos.
It's distracting.
It's really,
he's like,
yeah,
but if I do so like I'm in San Francisco this this week,
if I'm,
so that's my crap.
They all know I have tattoos.
It's different.
But if I'm at the comedy store,
laugh,
track three or Improv,
I covered my tattoos.
That's interesting.
I think there's a,
there's a lot to be said for that.
I noticed for years now when I would tour with Joe that a,
he'd do a big show.
It was there.
Even when he would shoot,
he would wear like baggy long sleeve shirt.
Always.
Always,
never like showing that he's in shape.
Never showing the tattoos because,
and you're like,
oh yeah,
it just looks like a black shirt.
Like you just don't even think about it.
You listen to what he says exactly.
Um,
but I've never heard it from a male perspective because I've only ever heard it
dealt with it as a female comedy.
But I guess guys struggle too.
For sure.
Well,
I'm already in.
I don't mean to interrupt.
I'm like,
I'm way too into fashion where if you guys didn't know I was engaged like Oh,
he's gay as shit.
Yes.
I'm super into fashion.
I everybody thinks you're good.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
yeah,
that's fair point.
But um,
I'm super into fashion super into fashion where I'll pick up my out like I'm
outfit picked out for Thursday night show already.
I might have picked up for next Friday's show already.
Yeah,
I like it.
I bet you do.
Do you pick out your own outfits or do you have a stylist if you looked at it?
I'm liking.
Ah,
no,
like I,
I,
you'd have swagged it was stylish for one,
for like one time when I was doing this thing on e and like we talked back and
forth.
I'm just like,
what?
You don't know what the fuck?
Like I know what's in like,
you're so old school lady,
you know what worked for Jared.
Leto isn't going to work for me.
We got one for you though,
if you want.
If you want to try someone else.
Oh yeah.
For Real.
Yeah.
We've got some of the,
all the stars,
the dudes,
it was tight.
You're like it,
like you hired them for your special maybe,
I don't know.
I sent the bill to my manager and they were like,
oh my God,
what are you wearing?
I was like,
no,
no.
He gave me a bunch of shit.
But sometimes it's good because let's say they give you some crazy Gucci jacket
and you do a special with that,
or you do the event with that.
Well,
you've got to give it back to him.
So he probably shouldn't pay for that because you can't rock that thing again.
It's tough to rock that again.
Yeah.
I mean like you,
she has,
she just shot a special,
and before you got here,
she started in Seattle,
but we just announced that it's airing,
uh,
on Netflix.
She has a,
uh,
a very fashionable Christian Dior dress.
I can't wear it again.
But then again I have in my closet it's like,
oh,
that's my special,
it's my first special dress.
But it's tailored like you can't take a wedding.
No,
it's like your body.
It's tailored perfectly.
I had to camouflage,
I had mask my big tits and you know what I mean?
You can give it to or you can give it towards his underwear.
Like when he's,
if you have a daughter,
she switches pronouns.
I'm so glad you said that because I think it's true that like while it's open
minded as people are at the end of the day you would be like,
why did this shit?
I love everyone that you've seen.
I named Kate on Tlc 12 year old girl who's born a boy,
but she's going through the whole bottom surgery and she's in high school and
going on blind dates and shit.
And I looked at my son's name is talking about,
look at in 10 years she went thought fuck,
I want,
can you imagine?
And she,
I was like,
you'd still love him.
Of course.
Nightmare,
but it would suck that.
What's the,
at least let's not act like it wouldn't like you would.
We would all love our children regardless,
but that going through that will be fun
and just as like a man,
if my son was like,
Yo Dad,
I'm gay as fuck.
You know I'm a power bottom bro.
I was like,
ah,
fuck.
He's going to take a little,
it's going to take a little while to get used to,
oh cool man.
I'm like,
damn,
there it goes.
Kind of normal life now.
You would adapt to whatever became for new normal.
I'm still going to love them,
but it's going to take like with Caitlyn Jenner,
I like his language.
When he with you though,
he's like,
I'm powered bottom as fuck bro.
That's like,
oh my God.
Like you take a little bit like with Caitlyn Jenner thing,
like everyone's like,
you just got to accept her.
I'm like,
I get that,
but I've known her or him as Bruce Jenner,
like gimme a fucking sit on.
That's fine.
Yeah.
What's wrong with even having the reaction of like,
Whoa,
what like that.
Even that reaction is considered hateful.
Like,
no dude,
I'm just for my entire life.
I'm just not used to it.
Yeah,
isn't that wild?
Did you know that?
Like,
so you don't know his story really.
But he was a,
I was born a woman born woman,
clearly the first female college and went into fighting professional fighting in
the UFC and then now he's not just a podcast and he started with standup and
he's the one standing on the same lineup.
And I'll say this,
I told Tom this when I saw you guys run the lineup because we really haven't
talked or met and I in the same lineup
and that night there was a guy on there who does it too.
We do stand up and he used doing horrible and I'm a,
again,
I'm super self conscious of that stuff because you know there's some gimmick
acts out there.
So he was going up there and just completely bombed and you came back like,
what the fuck is going on?
I was like fucking right.
And then you were like,
God,
I mean how,
how these guys get up night.
And I was so self conscious,
I'm like,
God,
I hope she don't talk shit when I go out there.
That's an every comic thing.
So every comic who hears anyone say something in their head things like,
ah,
shit,
wonder what they're gonna think about me every 100%.
Yeah.
And I'll say this and this is why I'm a ride or die for Tom.
Like I'll kill someone for Tom because I did a set at the laugh factory.
It is a bunch of comps or delete account,
Tom,
everyone,
you know when you first getting started,
like get the,
you know,
you guys know how it is.
And I came up different.
He,
my path to this has been completely different than a lot of people's for God
sakes.
So I'm not,
I feel like Charlie Sheen doing tiger blood like you,
we have no idea.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
um,
I was doing to set the laugh factory and then you,
Tom text me after as I came in,
uh,
you can do this like,
dude,
you can do this man.
And just that little bit of encouragement.
Just fucking,
I mean skyrocket.
It's the positive route.
I do fear and hatred,
you know what I mean?
I'm like,
do I go negative so that I motivate you that,
yeah.
Oh,
but see what the wrong too.
But how would you motivate you that Ah,
not for you.
No.
What would you tell Brandon?
I would never discourage somebody trying.
I discourage people who don't try the hate and don't try actually met Brendan.
I was at a fight.
He doesn't even know this bit probably,
but I met him at a fight and I cheered against him
know,
so I was going to these fights because I was,
I was,
I was touring with Joe Rogan's tickets.
Yeah.
But I was,
I was opening for him.
I think it was in Vancouver maybe.
Oh,
I found our Lawsky.
No,
I think I thought you thought Mitrione though.
Oh Bitch,
you're on.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
So Toronto,
but I don't know.
It's trying.
Okay.
I don't know any,
I didn't,
I didn't know anybody in the US,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I know some of the big names sometimes,
but yeah,
I mean I'm gonna,
I'm,
I,
you know,
I like football and stuff.
So I'm sitting there and Callen shows up and he's like,
my boys fighting in this.
And I was like,
who's your boy?
And so we're like,
we were just like the way,
you know,
and like,
and he's like,
he's coming up,
it's coming up.
And then he goes,
uh,
and he's telling me about like,
this is what this guy does.
This was this guy.
He goes,
yeah,
my boys fighting this guy.
He used to play college football.
So then I go,
you know,
I'm like a big co who,
where he goes,
uh,
he says,
metrio and I go,
I go,
where do you play ball?
He goes,
I thought he said Lsu.
So I go,
Lsu.
I go,
that's my dog.
I'm like,
go,
tigers do,
let's see.
You know,
mentioned it.
He never mentioned it.
So,
so then at the winds I go,
Yo man,
like Alex,
he was going to fuck you up like yelling.
And then at the fights,
man,
it was amazing.
I was sitting next Callen you
would've thought it was Cowens seven year old son.
I mean,
he was like nervous as shit.
He was so nervous and like,
like,
uh,
trying to get your attention like every fucking five seconds.
I was like,
and I kept being like,
your boy's gonna get fucked up
dude.
He was like,
he wasn't listening to anything I was saying.
He was so,
and you won that fight and then when you won the fight he can lost his mind.
Yeah,
dude,
he,
he was,
he was like,
it was like a father and son,
which he could be since he's that much older than you.
100%.
My Dad,
my best friend's about 53 minutes.
What's crazy about that fight?
That was like the kind of one,
the first steps into me transitioning from swinging of Caitlyn Jenner,
but me transitioning from a kind of that arena into entertainment through
podcasting.
Because especially at the time,
there's no Reebok deal.
I want to get too much into that,
but you could wear any sponsor you want.
So I could wear a,
uh,
you know,
your guys' podcast shirt out.
I could wear Reebok,
Nike,
whoever I want to.
And so for that particular fight I wore our podcast shirt,
Abbot Kinney Fight Club podcast.
And so I turned down money from these companies to where my own podcasts.
You were a big baller brand before big baller brand.
Exactly.
The UFC was like,
you're an idiot.
And I was like,
that's fine.
Let me wear my podcast smart.
That's where it started to take.
That's crazy.
School and podcasting has exploded for you guys.
Yeah,
it's been good man.
Which you know what's crazy,
you know a lot of fighters or try and match it with comedians because they think
that's what makes the fire in the kid.
But it's not.
And that's your guys' chemistry.
Yeah.
Cause you have two best friends talking.
We don't really even talk about sports,
talking about life girls,
whatever,
politics and current events.
But,
so you see a lot of people try and copy it,
which is flattering.
But,
so they get some fighter who is better than me and some comic more famous and
Callan,
you'll hear,
do a podcast.
We assist success like those guys.
It just doesn't work.
No,
it's lightning in a bottle.
It's chemistry,
which you can't duplicate.
And totally man trail.
And then,
and then we started doing live shows.
That was Karen's idea.
And then I left that old man and the dust and who I am.
It's crazy.
I don't know.
Okay.
And UFC stuff,
do they talk shit?
Is it,
is it like boxing?
For sure.
I remember more so than boxing.
Let's talk about how do you plan your shit?
How the,
uh,
the,
at least the way of that,
me and metro and you guys were talking,
Matt.
So Matt and I were friends before the fight,
way before.
We're on the ultimate fighter together,
which is a reality show.
We're on that together.
And we had a trainer before that,
so me and Matt and I've always been bonded one way or another.
So when they called us to fight,
um,
I got a text from my manager and I'm like,
oh fuck.
Then when we fight,
man,
I want to fight Matt.
And so I texted him like,
hey bro,
I just got an offer to fight you in Toronto.
And Matt's like,
what?
And he goes,
oh,
I just got down for two.
And I was like,
well,
we can't turn it down.
She can't do now in fights,
the bad luck.
Um,
and I thought I'm matched up well with Matt and you know,
got to eat.
So,
um,
I texted him,
I just said,
hey,
I'm going to accept the fight.
Let's sell the shit out of this thing.
Let's just talk as much shit as we can.
So there is that element most most time.
There's not in a sic,
let's talk as much shit as we can.
Don't take anything personal.
I'm gonna say some roots shit.
He put got it,
have fun,
see you the date of the fight.
And I,
but cool man.
And so he starts talking shit to me on social media and he's like,
you look like you have down you and uh,
you,
you look like Adam Sandler and a down syndrome mom had a kid.
And I put,
I put,
and this is true,
yeah,
we'll in a times going through a divorce,
I,
but yeah,
that's not what your wife was saying when we had that mean greet together.
She was,
I fucking me.
And then he just took offense to that.
And when was I texted my cow dairy and then he got serious and they have to
fight.
He was dead serious.
Yeah.
And how about after that?
Oh,
we're cool.
Cool.
Yeah,
so I just did a,
uh,
commentating job for his biggest fight of his life.
He thought mass square guttering,
it's fate or,
and how's the commentator on it?
Kind of psycho.
He Won.
He knocked.
Oh,
cool man.
30 seconds.
So I saw him after.
I mean,
we're good.
He's been on my show.
It does
now as a very,
like I said,
very casual and there wasn't a fade or like an indestructable at some point.
He's just older,
so it'd be like,
it'd be like a,
Terry brought Bradshaw all playing for papers Steelers.
But there was a moment,
right there was a moment was the best of all time.
People were like,
this guy is like,
yeah,
but then testing kicks in,
competition gets better and he's a little old school,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not good for metro.
Put Jim Brown at running back like,
mm.
Wasn't even really good.
Like you're fucking grip ago.
Yeah.
It's like that.
Are you in a football team?
I know nothing,
Bro.
I am a woman.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Football man.
I do love you.
So crunk gets here.
I'm super excited.
But you know,
I'm a big seminal fan and our quarterbacks out for the season,
game one and then you go off.
Tough opener.
Fuck yeah,
it was man.
And there was,
and they caught someone lucky breaks and I mean,
that game could have been a closer game,
but I go,
tough game.
It's a tough game.
Yeah.
It's a tough game to opal with.
But I still go like,
ah,
man.
Like if he'd be,
if he was healthy coming out of that game,
you know,
I still feel fine.
Oh definitely.
Great ball making the playoffs with a backup in.
It's going to be able to state though like the,
the backups going to be a stuck.
He's,
he's six,
five,
one 85 and their whole line is suspect.
I mean that kid trouble France while I was getting hit,
like you would not believe it's also Alabama.
This guy I know,
but this guy weighs one 85 about to get crumbs.
I mean we're gonna have,
we're gonna have it tied in throwing the baseball be dealt with.
It's going to be,
it's gonna be rough man.
So theoretically these are your friends that you're fighting with,
correct?
It's,
it's your,
it's like,
it's like no,
in a comic it's like me Texting,
I dunno,
Ari and being like,
hey dude,
I'm gonna fucking beat your face in,
in three months exists with roasts.
Right?
Cause you roast friends.
That's true.
But it's not physical.
Like I'm saying like he loves people like us all.
Ralphie may get his feelings hurt.
Yeah,
I've heard about this.
And that's,
that's happened.
I mean Ralphie's was highly publicized but it's also happened on ones that don't
air where you hear about somebody getting real upset like in the back.
Yeah.
Like sometimes people who are like the fuck and you're like,
I've,
I've heard comics.
So you know how when you play,
when you do like tag off where there's no host,
what do you call it?
Yeah,
team tacting so when they have to introduce the next time,
I've had comics roast off fuck out of me before I get up there.
I mean the thing about those roasts,
it's weird to me is when it's not friends.
I wouldn't mind being roasted by friends for sure.
I mean I'd sign up being funny.
Yeah.
But like when,
when I understand almost,
I think when some of the people get upset at the road cause they're getting
roasted by people they don't know.
And that's why it's Blasa who gets upset at a roast.
I agree.
But I think that's why they get upset.
It's because they end up getting slammed by someone.
They're like,
who the fuck are you?
You shouldn't get upset.
But you also shouldn't sign up for this cause that definitely is a no,
you meant asking him to physicality.
Like how do you like you theoretical,
you like the person that you're going to fire.
Right.
So how,
I know it's not like I'm fighting Brian Cowen like,
like me and Matt,
we're friends but we're friends through the business,
you know?
So it's just part of the game.
Yeah.
So what'd you fight a friend?
Could you even do it physically?
I mean now definitely not.
When I was fighting is almost,
you know,
even guys,
I didn't know I had a problem hurting.
Like every fight I've ever had,
I always went to the back and like Yo Bro,
you all right.
Well even if I lost like,
hey man,
you good?
I'm like,
yeah,
get the fuck out.
I'm like,
I just check.
What is it like I always,
I imagine too nice to be like nice to be a world champion.
Kind of a gentle giant as way too nice to be.
What's the anxiety like walking to the,
Oh my God.
The worst it is,
right?
So work cause I was here a fun.
Did you shut a lie or Maria Ho vomit not to pee nonstop.
Never.
It never diarrhea but always had,
I was like God,
he's so much cause I drink fluids and then for every file,
every,
every fight.
So for the last one is a little different.
Before I retired,
every fight I'd be in the back going,
what the fuck am I doing?
What am I doing?
Like I get to go out.
You're,
you're seeing the movie gladiator when they're about to go out and he's chained
to that dude.
He looks down,
he's pissing his pants.
It's just,
it felt so barbaric.
It is nuts.
Now how about this,
cause I,
I actually didn't know this until I was reading about you sometime.
I was reading something that you were golden gloves.
Yeah.
It was a golden gloves champion in Colorado.
But when did you start boxing?
So I only started boxing to pursue the UFC to get them and maybe kill.
Was it after?
It was so I started doing like,
like messing around.
Boxing was in college and training.
Can I do it?
Just stay in shape for
football.
And then I was like,
Dang,
I'm not bad.
And then went to the NFL,
had literally a cup of tea with the buffalo bills.
They're like raw set on white guys and then sent me back home and I was like,
what the fuck am I going to do?
And then enter the Jitsu competition,
uh,
one that,
and then you had no Jujitsu training.
I had like a six months,
eight months of training one that,
and then,
uh,
the guy was trained with that time.
Shane Carlan who's UFC heavyweight champ.
He goes,
Hey,
uh,
next week is going gloves.
I'm like,
oh that's cool.
Boring as shit.
Let's go.
He's like,
I signed you up for it.
I'm like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
you're in it man.
Cause I was sparring with him on and off and so he took to,
do you think,
I mean,
is it one of those things where you took to it naturally box?
Some of it.
I just outworked everyone to be honest.
Like my,
yeah,
like I just,
I wanted it more like,
especially in like golden gloves.
I had like eight fights and I had,
I had all eight stoppages,
nothing went to decision.
So it was just like,
I,
it's just your,
your heart,
especially when you're starting out like it to have a big heart.
I mean,
so much.
Wow.
I also have a lot of their options,
so coming out ways that are fucking teaching moms cardio,
kickboxing.
I gotta make it here,
man.
That's the goal with my brother.
My truck was getting repoed.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I going to do when you graduated Colorado,
right?
Yeah.
And then do you get,
like,
you have NFL hopes at that point?
Oh my God,
this is my dream.
Yeah.
So how does that,
like,
what's the process like?
Like there's obviously like there's combine people and the draft and then you
get an agent and you're like,
look,
I mean,
yeah,
you get an agent like right in between.
So we went to a ball every year.
Let's see,
every year I played in the big 12 championship,
so he can play in big talk,
jump ship,
and then you get to Bulger right in between that bowl game.
Uh,
usually talking to agents,
you kind of have an idea.
I had some coming my way and they're like,
yeah,
maybe late round draft pick free agent.
We'll see.
So then you watch the draft,
don't get picked up.
Best friend get strapped in the sec around the met is draft party brokenhearted
and then nothing happens.
Then weeks later like hey buffalo,
the buffalo is going to,
you know,
bring in to train.
What happens when you get that call?
And I was at like static.
Yeah you're just like fucking flying right flying.
But I knew it was,
I was still a long shot cause their,
it's like hey,
someone got hurt.
They need a body basically if you're super gifted you might make the team.
So I remember flying down there,
tell him my family and friends like,
dude,
I know how this game goes.
A chance of me making this team are not fucking good.
Don't get all crazy.
You know you're flying into buffalo,
flying into Buffalo.
And so I fly to Buffalo,
get off the plane,
go through like this weird little combine worked out and I'm there for not that
long.
A few days I injured my hamstring but to me it was like,
it,
it broke my heart right away.
Right.
I'm a sensitive person but I realized how much of a business it was cause I get
there in like 43 you over there.
I'm like,
well my name's Brendan.
Like what the fuck over there?
And again,
no doubt.
And then it's just like,
it was just such a business that broke my heart.
It was like,
you know your entire life you want to get to Willy Wonka's chocolate factory.
You get in there and you're like,
God,
they treat these midgets.
And it's also crazy how like when you,
if you follow just like the NFL news ticker,
you know,
it'll be like big name guys and they're like release today and you know,
he's released and it's like well it's this much.
He was going to owe against the cap.
So they just cut the bring in a young guy and some other guy came up and then it
really becomes like,
like it was just such a business and you don't really think about that when
you're a kid.
You know,
like you just think you're going to get there and a semi all rainbows and Molly
and to be a good time.
It was not the case and that's how I was like,
oh my God.
And even towards senior year I'm like,
oh,
I don't want to do this for the rest of my life.
I don't play football the rest of my life.
Like my,
my dream when I was kids be on Saturday night live.
Like I was obsessed with Jim Carrey,
Adam Sandler,
I was just gifted.
I was just the big for you.
You had sex with a retarded Sandler.
Yeah.
There you go.
Corn to Matt mature.
Oh,
as part of your dream.
Yeah.
There you go man.
So for me it just,
it,
it was eye opening and it was a good experience and led me to where I'm at now.
But yeah,
you've had it.
You've come with now.
Uh,
do you remember in college you played,
you said,
and he's big 12 games.
You ever playing against any big name players today?
I'm a big name.
I mean I played hard,
played against uh,
Shit,
man.
I played uh,
Oklahoma when they had Adrian Peterson.
Who won the Heisman against in Jason White.
Had the Heisman.
Yeah.
Would be this 50 to nothing.
All my city,
I played against Vince young when they won the last championship against USC.
Do you remember some things,
the best college team help time you played?
He beat US 70 to three.
Wow.
And I was on kickoff return.
Oh,
it was horrible.
And I was going against this freak who made mate to the NFL and I mean,
how many fucking kickoffs is that?
And he,
every time don't touch me white boy.
I'm like,
Bro,
you guys are going a lot of points.
I have to touch you like to football.
I have to touch you man.
Don't touch me.
Fucking white boy.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm just,
that's what you get to see.
That's the kind of shit.
I love that shit.
Talking on the field,
you know,
don't touch me white boy.
When you're fight,
when you were fighting MMA stuff,
do you talk shit?
Why are fighting a dude?
Yeah.
See that's what I got a lot,
you know,
reverse racism.
Don't touch me white boy please.
You don't see Miami.
It's all they said to me.
So I'd be a long day.
That's what they really,
well you played Miami.
He played at Miami at Miami.
That is the epicenter of time.
Me and just hot as fuck.
So I think Sonora smoss caught this ball.
I was like,
oh my God,
we're him for a long day.
You played tight end,
the tight end fullback,
a fullback,
HBAC.
But I was a,
I was also on all the special teams saw my God freaks man.
Freaks,
freaks.
So,
uh,
do you remember,
is there like when you think back against the Texas team and Oklahoma,
just like,
do you ever have those hits where you're like,
oh,
like this dude,
I'll you in high
school I played against Heath Evans.
Oh yeah.
Who played in the NFL for like 10 years for sure.
And to this day I've talked to friends of mine that were on those teams.
We still remember what it was like to hit or be hit by leaf because it was so
different.
Like he was such a beast that like even if you hit him in the Backfield,
like your head shook and you're like,
ah,
yes,
like Jesus.
Yeah,
it's like a freight train took off.
You know,
it was like,
it was another level.
So I don't know if like in those games,
but you're playing against all studs,
but like all some of those guys are even crazier.
Right.
I'm trying to think.
There was like,
I see,
I never had,
cause I was on a,
I was on the offense,
but I remember seeing agent Ph and he was a freshman or sophomore in the hand,
the ball off to him and it was like tech mobile.
We're just keep hitting and he's just fucking sleeping guys.
And I remember Ron just like,
oh my God,
how such a,
how do people tackle him?
Yeah.
Like what are we going to do?
Yeah,
they score whatever 50 points in a row.
And I was just like,
I don't,
how has he not done,
how's he liking be the best in the world was those are the longest rides home,
right?
Like after those games?
Well,
I think the heartbreaking thing is identify salt Takeo spikes.
Yeah.
He's a linebacker and he has literally traps from here to here.
He's as dark as this table and what you're doing.
Hitting drills.
And he had his shirt off and I'm just like,
well,
we don't even look like the same species.
Like what the,
how the fuck am I gonna make the team?
And you're like a big dude.
That's a nice shit.
Can Be like,
as far as I know,
a UFC heavyweight or NFL play.
I'm just,
um,
I guess I've never seen a football player except for a Jay when he came over to
our house.
A hawk.
Yes.
He's a stud.
There's to kill spike.
Spike's look at his neck.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
You're right.
It's wider than his face.
No,
you could have muscle here.
That's a knack is wider than his whole face.
Man Freak.
This is problems for you.
This is a problem.
This d has stopped.
You should just been like,
go get a job.
It's like this ain't for you.
Like go get a job.
What are you doing white boy.
I'm like you have.
That's a great point.
I think Christina and I are definitely interested in we,
we bring this up as often as we can love.
That's where
I was going to go there.
Diverse
cycled
where the difficult task.
Some first questions.
I even wrote it down.
It's funny,
you and I are in the same way of like,
oh,
we're really talking about Dick.
All right.
What's up though?
They speak my language.
Fuck these black athletes.
I bet Takeo spikes.
Tick looks a lot like his neck.
Well,
let,
let's put back that ass up thick.
I'll tell.
I'll tell you about the biggest one I've ever seen.
I know.
First of all,
I'd like to ask a very important question.
Who's balls were smelly or MMA fighters or football players or are weird
questions?
I say slope.
I propeller opening a clip.
I would say I'd say football because you had this big stinky lineman who don't
really give a fuck about hygienic hygiene.
And my friend Josh Potter,
we always have this conversation.
Okay,
Josh Do.
Josh is a comic and he,
he's from Buffalo and uh,
he says which position has the cleanest assholes in the NFL and the dirtiest and
cleanness to be senator.
Oh,
see he,
no,
he disagrees.
He says that like quarterbacks have like a one like and corners and the wide
receivers Tivas just like diva superclean assholes.
And that basically the argument comes down to o line and dealer and this is
where we,
we've often had a heated debate.
I that's sloppy ass fat ass.
Oh.
And have to have the dirtiest assholes.
He says it's d linemen.
And part of his theory is that the,
the aggression,
the chasing if you will,
makes it a sign guy.
We just saw the picture of what's his position.
He was a linebacker.
His ass.
I mean it depends,
it's case to case.
Yeah,
that's the case.
I mean,
is he a Mike as you will
see a weak side.
I mean,
you know it's a strong side running a three floor.
They were in the fourth,
I don't know.
You know it's he blitz all the time.
There's a lot of variables,
but coverage linebacker,
what are we thought about?
I mean this guy dropping back and zone.
What's he doing?
So,
but Paul Humor.
Nice.
A lot of,
a lot of football.
Asshole humor though.
See,
I think center because they know,
they know the ones that school's getting.
It played with Sophie of Tom Brady putting that,
those hands that those golden hands underneath your route.
You would never disrespect that.
No,
it's Tom Brady son.
He's probably like that shit clean today.
Of course.
You better man.
I see another photograph of that gentleman.
We were,
we were looking at her like,
I need to see the whole body
detectives.
We like to guess what the person's Dick looks like.
We're talking girth,
length balls.
I play with a kid and he was a stud in the NFL too.
His name's Lawrence Vickers.
Why don't you guess his cock size?
Okay,
hold on.
Hold on.
Well,
let's look at photographs first.
Jesus,
look at God.
How tall is this guy?
Probably six one meat and cheese.
Was he way to 35 to 40?
Like complete rock solid,
not an ounce of fat on them.
Makes me look like a Dell shredding.
Normally I would go short fat,
coke can,
lot of girth.
I'm going to go long and lean on the painter.
Ooh,
this guy and I'm going to go extra long,
extra long and lean and then I'm going to go high and tight on the bosses.
Two big ass dicks for you right here.
Patrick Willis and to cats sitting on the bench to the best of all time,
but two of the best who are basically like we're about to run a train.
They retired enormous painters.
These guys.
So your,
your prediction is that there are long and lean and lean.
I'm seeing a lot of lean black dicks
usually like vein.
Yeah.
Thickies,
Nagle affect x,
right?
Yeah.
Like uh,
like uh,
again I I had a guy should a locker with what his locker was next and he's the
captain on our team.
His Dick was so big cause name's Lawrence Vic.
Cause you can look them up.
It was so big he could grab it and talk into it like a mic or swear to God.
He joke around by Kay,
how you doing?
They literally grab it like a Mike Fattest pick I've ever seen.
This is Lauren from the fifth ward and Texas.
Lawrence Vickers play for Cleveland browns for grip was our captain.
Our team,
the biggest Dick I've ever seen.
It was normal right here.
That's my boy.
She's right from Houston,
Texas.
Play for the cowboys.
What did he play?
Running back.
What is he?
He was like an h bache run back.
Fullback freak man.
Jesus.
Great Leader.
Fantastic of ever say,
shout out to Lawrence Vickers.
Huge black neck or his balls like not bad either.
Is this him hearing it so under the Lord.
That's amazing
though.
The MMA fighters,
are they the football player to what?
Rashad Evans packing heat.
Really?
Yeah.
How about this page?
I use Google to Kaos Spike.
For some reason,
this picture of a Broderick Bunk Lee came up.
I bet he's got a fucking peace
punk Lee.
I mean,
he's looking at you like you must see a big Dick Dude.
That's his weight.
Three Oh six and that's his way.
And he came in with like 7% body fat freak.
Yeah.
You're not gonna have a small Dick and be that freaky.
Oh Man.
It's just not the way it works.
Well that's not true,
Tom.
In the past you've said that it's sometimes it's,
it's,
you know,
irrespective of what I brought to her that she was just like a call.
Guys dig,
dig in short.
And I go with some short guys,
have some big old decks I've seen.
Kalynn has one of these sticks I've ever seen.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Is a fat Dick Rogan has a fat thick too.
Really the only hang out with does that dicks like you've got,
you've,
you've checked them out though.
Yeah.
Seen Him with my own eyes.
What?
At the gym or just like,
you know,
hanging around.
The first time I met county we are taking a piss and I,
she was telling her,
I looked over and just see what he's working with.
She's talking so much shit.
I chat to see for myself.
It's like seen a white walker.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a hat.
See it for myself.
Then you're like,
oh that's pretty impressive though.
You're not lying man.
Cause I didn't know if I could trust them or not.
But he's thick,
thick and long and long surprise for column B and 50 thinking long balls are
long on kaolin grandfather balls and Joe,
I just saw,
you know if that Dick,
yeah,
you didn't see the balls.
No,
I just wanted to say
Lawrence,
Lauren's Vickers into cows
back.
You're welcome here anytime.
Anytime you come on by by guys.
Brendan,
I'm glad you're here today because this is the start of a brand new debate on
your mom's house.
Very hot topic.
Uh,
Tom and I were eating breakfast and in the middle of the meal he says,
I have to take a shit.
But then he finishes eating and then shuts after.
Now me on the other hand,
if I'm eating and I have to shit,
I get up,
I leave,
I take a shit,
I come back and I'd just eat my food cold.
Where are you on this side of the debate?
Well,
um,
with this um,
yes,
dumpster.
So I keep it,
I keep it sexy.
If I take a shit,
I just telling you what,
I just kind of disappear and then come back.
But would you eat your entire meal?
Would you finish your meal or would you get off during the og it up?
Yeah.
I don't want be uncomfortable.
That's what I'm saying.
Depends where I'm at though.
Em,
at home.
Am I eating with my girl at home?
Oh Man.
Nice restaurant.
You're far in front of her?
No.
Wow.
Keep it sexy man.
You gotta keep it sexy.
How long have you been together?
Five years now.
That's why
she does the same.
Oh yeah,
I be him.
Well,
did you see her give her that up in here?
What did you see her give birth,
the section I was,
but you didn't see not and I tried to stay away from it,
but yeah,
there's like a little corner I could see through his rough serious surgery.
She's Mexican.
Yeah,
Mexican is,
fuck,
look at that.
Double A to,
you know,
hey,
the motherfucker come on here.
Hopefully his owner ain't outside.
You know what I'm saying?
I watch,
I went,
I'm doing and I don't want to cause a car come on here.
But you know when you're Mexican,
you know Mexican survive.
Do what they gotta do.
You know,
saying,
you know,
that's why we make skis.
Of course,
doing something that what I'm doing,
that's what we do in Mexico,
Bro.
You know what he's doing?
What?
He's taking a shit outside.
Oh Wow.
Hey guys.
Good morning guys.
I'm here chilling thing,
going to shit outside saying some reason the restroom.
I ain't going to shit my motherfucking beds.
You know what I mean?
Shows I'm wearing shorts,
usually the shit of shorts.
He's just working dog
in a fucking regular.
Just outside.
That's what Joey did.
Had to be my son.
I might be my son.
And if 20 years you can make this video.
Hey pops,
what's up bro?
What's up man?
Told down power bottom hog.
Just Shit my period.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
that's him,
man.
He's gotta take a shit.
That'd be a bummer.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a motherfucking video to show you how I'm doing.
I know what I'm saying is,
is there anything you don't want your kid to be like?
Is there something you just so adamant on you don't want them to be?
I can't think.
I know.
You know what I,
I feel like it is whatever it is that you're like,
Oh God,
whenever you have that thought of like just so irritated by something,
sometimes my mind goes,
that's what's going to happen.
That's cool.
I mean,
yeah,
like,
and it's not necessarily like we're going to be like,
it's like when someone like when it irritates you when someone's being
indecisive,
if you like,
what are you going to do?
And then
my mind will go,
that's what that's I'm going to get as payback.
They're super negative.
Yeah,
that's it.
And honestly you can't help if the,
if super like manic depressive or something,
that'd be a bummer.
I used to live in your basement playing video games and shit.
I don't want my kid to go to,
I don't want him to go in the military only because I don't want my baby to die
in a war that's,
I just don't want that.
That's fair.
But what about entertainment?
Oh God,
it's a terrible,
but if he,
if he,
if he was,
I think it might be like it's just going go like extreme one way or the other.
It's either going to be like,
I definitely want to do what you guys want to do.
They're like,
what you guys,
I hope it's the opposite me to stand up.
I definitely hope he doesn't get it.
No,
not really.
Yeah man.
It's not a career path,
but I would recommend to most people,
you know,
it's a lot of suffering.
It's a lot of like the grind is real.
It's really real man.
And like you actually got to come in at a point where like you have success in
other aspects of your life to kind of hold you up as you do it.
But like if you were 23 I can't imagine I came to relate to it.
Like I can really throw it as far because I had a debate with one comic.
They're like,
wall while you were out playing grab ass.
I was on the ground and I was like,
well,
it's getting punched in the face.
It's a little different,
but I'm saying like,
uh,
also like,
I mean,
I know you could,
this is kind of being negative,
but like the probability of things,
even just like remotely working on my Solo,
I mean,
you have a better chance of graduating Harvard law getting a,
well,
because to get into Harvard,
I can sit my son down,
go look,
do this,
this and this.
You get into Harvard.
If my son goes,
hey,
I want to be the next Tom [inaudible] girl.
I go,
I guess try and do this.
It might lead you here and then you've got to do this and hopefully this works
out and they got it no more and you got to eat more and lay down and there's no,
there's no,
there's no blueprint.
That's one of the hardest things about showbiz.
He's like,
you think like,
I should follow this person's path.
And you're like,
everyone's path is completely different.
Completely different.
And they got to stay relevant.
Exactly.
Are you enjoying,
uh,
like,
you know,
I mean obviously like you're having success,
it's kind of wild,
but like are you enjoying,
you know,
figuring it out?
Best time of my life.
Really.
Yeah.
It's been a complete blessing,
which is not combining religious,
but uh,
it's just,
it's been crazy,
man.
It's been great.
I've always wanted to do this and I think just figuring things out and making it
work and being on the road and show business.
It's been amazing,
man.
Like I just had a meeting last week about,
you know,
a TV show for something I've always wanted to do.
Like what?
I should a guy like a meeting they'd like be,
shouldn't be taking these meetings,
scripted show.
Uh,
no,
like a house show for,
because I do my podcasts,
big brown breakdown,
be like that for TB.
That's awesome.
That'd be great.
Be Great.
But just stuff like that.
Your dreams are coming true,
dude.
Yeah.
Or like,
like for me,
like when I,
cause I live in Santa Monica,
so when I drive down sunset to do a set the comedy store,
it's like I get so excited,
man.
I get so,
so excited.
And like,
my biggest thing that I miss from sports was not the fighting,
not playing the football games were like the camaraderie with the guys and like
bone out.
When I go to the comedy store,
when I'm in the back,
it's you Burt crystally a Rogan Brian.
Like it's like fuck,
here's the monitoring guys man.
True.
And like,
I feel safe.
That's the nice part that is,
I feel like the punter on the football team,
but I feel safe.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like the punter,
like exactly part of the team.
I'm the weird punter,
but I feel safe.
But you know,
with a few bits I fuck up a few more years.
You'll be a long snapper
for the field goal kick and slowly,
slowly fat d linemen that still,
oh my God.
Uh,
Jean Jean Jean.
I have this guy.
Oh,
vocal fry.
You know about vocal fry?
I don't,
I kind of have it right now,
but it's because I'm sick when we talk too much.
No,
it's like when people will elongate their local,
oh my God.
Yeah.
So it's like we're always like pat,
you know,
like we're kind of obsessed with at what is that?
Yeah.
It's like not the way people really talk,
you know?
And Oh my God,
meditation.
Meditation.
So the interesting thing about vocal fry that we did a lot of research and we've
been learning about,
it's just that that's completely deliberate.
She knows exactly what she's doing that on purpose.
Even if she's,
it's almost an act.
Yes.
It's a front.
It's like,
yeah,
you're
making your voice,
dude,
upper class girls to sound more intelligent.
That sounds intelligence and exclusive.
I think.
Maybe,
maybe not intelligent.
I think they just cool.
They think they are more exclusive.
Like I'm in a
house.
Would you talk?
Well I'm saying like,
I think that they're thinking like,
oh,
this is how Kim Todd
super hard and you really like suck Cox with
the first day.
Speak to this too.
Like it makes them sound smarter.
But why smarter?
I don't think it makes us think it's supposed to be like a,
yeah,
it's like a cool thing to do.
That's why it's like the,
the kind of cliche
thing to do right now.
It'll phase out.
I hope so.
Yeah.
So the first thing that you want to do that when you're starting a meditation
was get a good comfortable seat.
I'm comfortable sitting up on a cushion.
Oh by God.
Hers is outrageous style.
One foot is in front of the other and my vagina crossed out of line up in front
of each other.
Well,
yeah,
you can't have that.
And what you do,
is there some for guys when they talk like that now guys just do talk.
No,
there's actually a fighter fighter does the talks like that who took the
blanket?
He was a world class boy tie fighter up.
Oh yes.
Yes.
And however you need.
And his is one of the worst cases.
Yes,
yes.
Really have audio of him.
But I can pull it out.
No guy recently though,
like there's no guy and this guy,
I'm talking like this.
Yeah.
Listen to this guy.
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
She's a beautiful girl who I'm very much in love with and I have a lot in common
with.
I can't wait to get home.
And he's like,
no,
dude,
that's a real dude.
He um,
what's that show called?
Uh,
polyamory.
Oh,
I watched that show on showtime.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was all right.
The second 13.
Yeah.
I like this class.
Yeah,
it was great.
And I like tall and you know those dirty hippies and all live together.
Yeah.
There are so nasty.
It was so interesting.
I love this has him.
Oh yes.
I remember that guy.
See he got a gym and his girl was hot.
Yeah,
he had his show.
It was all fun and games.
Someone the fucking pill.
There was that show and it did show [inaudible] Juggalos too,
right?
Yeah.
We're huge into that show too.
What the fuck?
Some fellow Giglio.
So check this out.
I saw homeboy because I used to live in Venice.
I saw nick McFalls me on Twitter.
Oh yeah,
nick on DME.
Nick.
Yeah,
but I'm the bald guy.
The one who's like,
actually,
you know,
I consider myself a feminist feminist.
Yeah,
he is the best one.
The bald one.
Yeah,
I'll wait for which went down every girl regardless.
Oh then yeah,
so I saw vin with like a girl pushing a stroller by Starbucks and you would've
thought I saw fucking Oj Simpson went,
oh shit am I girls like my girl watch too.
She goes,
why?
I went,
it's vin and I go,
Bro,
give it up.
And he's like,
oh my God,
you will give it a brother.
And he's like,
Whoa,
okay man.
It goes like that and just scurries off.
Whoa.
I don't ask anyone for any pictures.
I would have got that picture.
Yeah,
he was with a girl with a stroller?
Yes.
Wow.
Interesting.
And I'm like,
maybe his mom,
I think maybe keeps it on the DL.
And I was like,
Yo man,
you gotta Dick Somebody down,
you know,
like on the pier.
And it was like too much though.
Would you now,
if you had to hook your lady up with somebody,
like you're off at war and you're like,
I gotta get you a prostitute.
What you got.
Would it be Vin and I'm hiring the cowboys and angels.
Yeah.
No,
I would hire the,
the dude who was shred and super into yoga.
Yeah.
And he had long great
body.
He connects.
Connects.
What's his name?
Angel.
No,
I'm going crazy.
I know you're talking about and he's got the long hair and he always flipped it
to his side.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we'll hire nick used to line just to,
I dunno,
I didn't trust him.
The of the old guy.
I like brain breaks has been on our show.
Rice was on the show.
Talks like that multiple times.
This brass ash.
Ash Ash.
Yeah.
Cause also he's going to be like let's get our chakras threat.
It's more like a chicken afterwards.
She'd be like,
that was really special.
Thank you.
Now I'm going to go back to Brendan cause he's an animal.
But brace might give your girl a whole new world.
It gets fired after every now and that's our official,
fire it up.
And then you got nick too skinny.
Weird.
I love the rap battles.
He was so bad.
Oh my God.
Did you,
how about when they did the Bros when they had to write jokes and it goes down,
I can do this.
I don't need to write and just get up there and you never seen it completely
bombed.
Sparse.
It's great.
And then the guy that goes,
I've been working on my raps.
We're huge fans of Nick's videos to be seen as videos like on Youtube.
His music.
Come on,
you've got to go down the rabbit hole.
Ever done that?
Why did they stop making it?
I feel like they ran out of material.
They did like six,
seven seasons.
Why stop there?
Let's get a new crop of young cats who just dicking girls down.
I don't know.
Why don't I do an all black one?
Wouldn't you be into that false.
Some whores mixed up.
All girls.
I like that girls aren't trying to do it though.
I know the girls,
it's a bad look for the brace was like,
I be like,
I was like,
what's up you old ass hoe and like,
uh,
he was like,
just to be clear,
I'm not some back alley trick and look,
it's not like 40 bucks yet bro.
Like sticking my dick and I go,
come on man.
You know you're all home.
He like,
oh.
He's like,
I'm a high end.
Like they always like make it clean and escort.
Nah Bitch,
you're a whore.
You're just getting paid a ton of money for it.
He's actually very nice,
very sweet.
He's from the Midwest and he's like,
oh,
he's awesome.
He's really sweet guy.
He does a vitamin supplement line.
He wants to get into like health and your old offers $0 million see slanging
vitamins.
That's how this movie ends.
Slang environments and still dine is here.
What is that song called?
You remember I'm working in a sweat.
I'm breaking a sweat.
That's nick hawks jam.
It was born to be bad
from the film.
American justice.
It's not from the film
must be restored.
Shit.
My mind why you can't blame me for Rick?
You swap in my file.
I paid a lot more.
I walk a tight.
Wow.
I'm not mad at
feeling it.
Right.
I'm breaking a sweat.
I want,
it's my favorite is
breaking a sweat.
Trying to kill it because the other guys ain't doing shit.
I don't get one.
Nick doesn't come a Dj like Paris Hilton or herself.
Like what I'm seeing just pick girls down after the show.
It's a good idea.
Actually.
Deejaying maybe would be better lane,
right?
Yeah.
Like just put your iTunes podcast playlists on and just trying to see it up
there and you bore me.
Just Google a break.
I just put it on.
You know what I found when I put it into a break?
Making fun of us.
US,
Huh?
Yeah.
So I got that sat on that you sent me?
Yeah,
you did cheesy,
right?
He's a
comic book.
Here's the venom.
All umbrella theorizing on that.
Oh,
he's super airbrush.
Star shows up.
Maybe she'll pay this morning.
Huh?
Let's see.
Does the,
here we go.
We've played breaking this guy.
We're breaking,
breaking a sweat.
The name of the song.
If you listen to a few episodes back,
I don't remember the episode number.
We can look it up.
I'm sweating and will do for the hot or not like call us.
Let us know.
Do it for how long.
You can't really call us.
Seven years.
Certainly.
Let us know.
We can certainly comment on Youtube on,
yeah.
Let me see.
I want you to hear you out of here Bro.
Yeah,
no,
it's not for everyone.
It's just how music is.
Not Forever.
It's just not sometimes not.
Yeah,
he does it all though.
You know he raps poetry raps.
Yup.
Fellow tree is that rolls down.
You realize here's one of those guys that like he can't figure out life,
but it's one of those is how you can figure it out.
I was going to say
that is so accurate.
We've been trying to analyze him.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
I don't know that like you ever tried.
I'll join the swim team.
Fuck it.
I'll do the swim team
of Joe Rogan,
like shock Joe does everything and then figures out how to do everything well.
Right.
And like if he's like his retarded.
Yes.
Evil brothers,
younger brothers,
like a turtle.
I want to try like I do everything too,
but like none of it.
It's just a complete mess.
It's a mess.
And I love watching masses.
No,
he just can't figure it out.
Yeah.
You just,
yeah.
You know if you're like,
hey,
you don't need to,
you ups drive like that.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
And then you get to wall my like what the fuck?
You don't work at Walmart like new gig bro Gig man.
I'm trying to figure it out,
man.
Life coach.
Yup.
Oh He's doing coaching?
No.
Oh that's right.
He is in my buddy signed up for it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
He's doing confidence coaching and teaches you how to be confident.
Yes,
that makes sense.
Cause you gotta be a competent motherfucker to fail.
So many times,
so many avenues.
Just keep going.
Like maybe you can learn a lot from,
I don't know how much he's charging per class,
but all I can tell you,
your boys signed up for it.
They can't be a lot of signups for that.
If you want it to be better with cooking,
talk to chef.
You want to be better with comments?
Talk to me.
Nick Hock ranging,
ranging Skypes and emails or phone calls ranging from $25 a hundred what about
in person though?
Whoa.
Four hours at my rate.
wow.
Come.
Wow.
You don't wait.
You don't rise to the top of the most sought after profession.
Star on a TV show for six years.
Perform your own music and Las Vegas as big as clubs or become self made by the
age of 35 of being.
Anything less than confident.
I'm sold.
Why wasn't always that way?
Can you please do to the world?
Much of my life?
Yeah.
Oh,
Brendan,
please take the seminar.
Oh,
here's a book.
Nick Hawks hundred kicks in the ass.
A guide to getting comments and reaching your full potential.
I mean,
the guy's killing it.
He's trying to be a fucking Tony Robbins.
I get it.
You start to figure life out.
Like you were saying,
you just figuring it out.
Fucking who knows if this doesn't work.
I Dunno what happened.
Why didn't we do it here?
I know,
right?
Those guys like all look down on it to what's going on here.
Is She just shoot member?
That was his photo.
All the show.
The shoot.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
On that.
Where we are working with it.
I'll tell you if you should be writing confidence books.
She hit really?
His Dick is right there on his website.
Maybe it is.
Yeah.
It's from hustle.
That is confident.
That's unprofessional.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
good job,
man.
I mean,
I don't hate,
I really don't hate him.
I respect the hustle.
I just hope he fought.
You know?
I hope he hits that home run because he's in a bunch of foul balls right now.
Like if his life is a baseball game,
he made up,
oh Joe foul balls to a foul ball.
He is a lot of salt.
You know what?
He just needs Jesus.
He's one of these people.
I need to do you think so?
Yeah.
He needs a come to Jesus.
He's the Lord.
That could be your kid,
man.
What up your boy turned into a male.
Whoa.
What'd you be proud of him?
Like a professional.
He's just like a player.
No,
no,
like no.
Oh God.
Then I failed as a parent.
Yeah.
It was
just God damn you act to what are you doing?
He's like,
I'm getting paid to fuck that.
Oh,
sorry.
It was so you do it.
We were both competitors,
man.
Trying to keep out dog.
I'm in my own lane,
man.
Yeah,
Dude.
Have a self help book coming out next month and he keeps showing you his dick.
[inaudible] this thing,
man,
this thing and yours better than that fucking Lawrence Vickers bitch you played
with.
What's your nightmare,
Brennan that your child?
Um,
one of those trolls on the Internet.
Like something,
sometimes I'll get a troll on the Internet and I,
I won't block or anything.
I DM them and cause I'll go to their page.
If they're not private,
most trolls are,
I will go to his page and if he has kids,
I'll just DM them.
Go,
listen man,
you have a right to your opinion.
You're a dad.
You have a fucking,
you really?
Yeah.
I go,
you have a kid.
Certain ones are you?
You have a kid,
man.
I go in 20 years,
do you want to be that guy that goes,
hey son,
I hate it on this guy.
He's way more successful than me.
Check it out.
And if you are single,
this is probably why,
man,
I'm doing a solid here.
Do Yourself.
Do they ever respond?
Don't be a loser.
Some of them be like,
fuck you.
And so I'm like,
God damn it.
You're right.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Usually I just blocked him.
Yeah.
Usually I don't even deal with it.
I don't.
You have to up them for me,
so I don't see it.
So I think everyone loves me.
I'm like,
what lives gray?
Have someone else watch how my brother will log in for you?
Oh yeah,
he has access to my account.
And you're like just black people that yeah,
I'll know like when stuff came out with,
you know,
Nick Diaz or when I was doing the showtime stuff,
some people might not agree with my opinions and so they'll try to,
you know,
troll.
So I'm just like,
Yo,
pay attention today and he'll just go through all of it so I don't see any of
it.
That's great.
I'm going to have Tom do that when my Netflix special.
No,
people love it.
Oh fuck.
Is that,
this is a clip from Christina's openings.
The opening?
Yeah,
she's talking to me.
Oh my God.
And then I'm like,
all right babe,
why don't you get on stage?
All right,
well it's fun.
We go.
Camera's rolling.
What's special is this way.
You can my first one.
What was your first one?
Yeah.
Well Damn,
congrats.
Thanks dude.
Damn man.
Netflix,
Netflix.
You're like shit.
Shit dog.
You garbanzo beans,
man.
I know.
I can't believe it.
Nervous what?
Uh,
no,
because I've been fucking doing it for so long.
Honestly,
I was not,
because I've been doing it for a minute and I,
how long have you been doing it?
14 years.
So I was like,
I was so on the zone dude.
I was like lacy go.
Wow.
Yeah,
but it's still,
it's still like I get it even though for a while,
but still Netflix now I'm now I'm more nervous to sit down and edit it and get
that process.
I Dunno,
it's a fucking trip because you just,
I performed in every shitbox and the country and I,
oh like you deserve it brown.
It's about
the God damn time.
Best Way to do so you know,
like to be like over ready to do it.
I think that's why I wasn't so terrified cause I'm,
I'm kind of am,
I'm like overcooked for it,
you know,
so I dunno
but switched on Netflix,
like if you shoot a good special on Netflix,
there's timeout game changer.
Like it make her breaks careers.
Like there's some guys where whatever,
they didn't put their best foot forward and then you kind of fucked when you go
back on the road if it's a bad specialist.
Cause now Netflix,
if I watched Dave Chapelle,
which is most successful special of all time,
most watched on if you guys know that.
Yeah,
he watched that and it goes,
you might also like,
and I watched Tom and yours and it's like,
ah,
what the fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's just not,
if you don't put your best foot forward,
especially these days specials and you guys know better than anyone really fuck
you.
I'm sure yours is great.
It's great.
I agree.
Like I,
I watched some people should,
I think a lot of times they're shot on Spec and so you don't know who it's going
to end up.
You don't know where it's going to end up.
And I do think some people are like whatever.
What do you mean?
Cause like sometimes when you shoot a special,
you don't necessarily have a buyer lined up slowly just shoot it on.
Um,
you know,
at the hopes of selling it.
And so maybe some people are like,
whatever.
It'll be like on this tiny platform,
no one's gonna see it.
And you know,
they don't really plan like don't make it that great.
[inaudible] over the plan.
Hi Mama.
Her hat
plan.
Shit.
I been done planning.
Yeah,
I've been done.
You're ready man.
Alright,
you ready Tiffany Haddish next couple of weeks over 10.
That is just killing it.
I love Tiffany.
She's fantastic.
I've never met her.
Oh,
she's the best.
Yeah.
Very,
very,
very talented.
Yeah.
She's got like some new movie deals.
TV.
She's killing it.
Killing it.
Just fantastic.
Um,
I hope everything works out obviously in your life and your marriage,
but if it doesn't,
maybe
any white,
I'm back with another Rep.
Hello.
Today.
And by the types of this with you,
you may have worked out the,
I am going to be doing their guide to getting a gun.
Oh,
the guy to getting a guy.
the guy to get that guy to guessing it down.
Yeah.
There's going to hook you.
Oh God,
man.
You know what I mean?
It's such a struggle.
Do you feel like he gets laid?
Ah,
yeah.
This guy go in your and your single days and you're fighting and plus there's
like a whole groupie like world talk about cage wrath is occasion page.
So
what you call Kay k,
they're just there for you guys,
I assume for you guys.
Oh,
you're fine.
When you're at,
you're in the UFC and you're fighting,
I mean everybody knows about NBA and NFL and like,
you know,
getting off the team playing and all that stuff.
But like here's the different roles solo.
Yeah,
here's,
but here's the difference.
So Nba Nfl,
they have NBA,
NFL money.
So again,
different type of hose,
right?
However,
if shit breaks down,
we can beat up any NFL and NBA player.
So there's that kind tribal,
yeah,
where girls go,
Holy Shit,
there's one Alpha Male,
right?
Give a fighter,
walks into a party and no matter,
even at the espys,
if fighter walks in the party,
everyone's like,
okay,
there's the Alpha genetically,
like going on Youtube.
It curls a little drawn to that.
However,
now I would say I get more hit on way more and more people slam [inaudible] now
more so than ever that I've gotten into comedy.
Niven Colin,
what?
Not even close.
Maybe it's because that might be it,
but also,
um,
may.
Yeah,
maybe.
Or maybe also,
you know,
one thing people like to do,
the common thing is they're like the laugh,
so they know.
I'll tell you why.
Brandon,
if you look at the pool of Dude's doing stand up here,
they'll looker of the bunch.
There you go.
Sorry.
Take take.
Take them.
Hey Man.
I've been doing this shit for 14 years.
I've been looking at the dudes in the Biz,
aside from my husband who's a Hanson,
who I married the dime piece.
There's not a lot of eye candy by the way.
A male comics.
So Brendan's handsome crystal.
Is that,
well,
hey crystal.
It's a little weird,
but he's a dynamo.
Yeah.
Chris,
you know,
you have a long neck,
but he's a little dynami.
Got a nice long neck and a lot of Nice long features on Chris.
Long feature means lean.
You see handsome young man.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Nice.
You've seen that dog?
I smelled it.
Oh Wow.
That was good.
I would say Chris,
most handsome dude and comedy,
he's definitely,
I mean,
I,
here's the thing.
I would say that there's a,
well,
we're going to go Tom,
just to,
you know,
I would say there's a,
or over the years there've been a couple of women than agree with you on Chris
three at least.
Yeah,
I guess,
cause there's some,
we are in a business of,
of not good looking guys.
You guys are talking about dogs,
the dog pound male comics,
dog towns.
I mean it's,
it's the place to succeed for like your,
the uglier and the worst.
Your attributes.
The WHO,
who was it?
Erik Griffin.
You know what Eric?
Yeah.
That's great.
I said at the,
at the Improv and he got in after me and he was like,
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Comics don't look like that.
Looks like this.
He'll lift his shirt up.
Yeah.
He's like,
that ain't comedy.
I was like,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I mean,
yeah,
I mean comics look like,
you know,
like shit man.
Like Bert,
like,
like you don't look good.
It looks good.
I think the tide is turned out because it's cool to work out and that's true.
Different things.
Who got Red?
He got big.
He got fic right.
He's clearly on t o t o with,
I mean TRT testosterone replacement because,
but he don't go from his,
he was 40 he was so skinny,
so skinny,
big humps.
That's where it came from.
And then now he's like,
no.
And Dr Dre got big,
he got like that ain't normal at his age.
Just get put on 30 pounds of muscle.
Yeah.
But now it's cool to be in shape.
That's true.
I think people just respect health more than,
you know,
it's like weird.
Like what much more so than 2030 years ago.
That makes sense.
You know,
people are always like,
I feel like Kipp top was the first
real Jackie.
Jackie,
thanks so much.
Steroids.
I bet.
Like he takes enough.
He might be able to,
you might be able to convince him.
He could beat you in a fight.
You know,
like,
do you got this shit man,
I'm tired.
Good chance.
He's crazy.
I don't want none of that carrot top fucking props and you would have to tape
the mouth shut cause he will bite the fuck you man.
For sure.
No,
but I think carrot top you have to,
I mean he looks,
he looks dirty out of his mind.
So surprise.
You have your teeth.
That's great.
Do you have all of them or they are original?
They're all mine.
I'd like a bit of an heiress,
but
those are nice.
Let's go back though.
You don't have to miss it.
I have perfect.
He's terrible.
Bobby.
The tension.
We see the bottom.
Wait,
wait,
let me say this first.
Never.
No races.
You're retired or crazy rush.
Once a day.
Once a week.
What?
Do you know what?
His teeth are pretty fucking French.
You drink coffee too?
Those are legit teeth.
Do you floss?
Oh my God.
You're supposed to got to start flossing.
It's going to change her whole game.
I'm telling you.
Let's do it.
Talent got Invisalign at 50 that's good.
He looks great though.
Karen.
Look cal,
it's great.
This is a little tough
time for it.
Official.
We have the nerves.
You have stood opposite.
What are you up in the nearest?
Do you still have to do all the regular dental protocol?
Here's the thing.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Just to be,
to get
clear for our audience here,
Brendan,
how would you grade his teeth?
Looking at them?
They look Nice,
right?
Does it very clean.
They're very straight.
They're very white.
Uh,
your gums look very healthy and not red and bleedy.
Um,
I think he's doing great.
So genetically or we use looking at like your teeth or do you have a lot of
dental work done or no,
zero seven years.
And my girl's mom is a dentist.
Holla at your boy because seven years ago,
let me see.
Smile.
Look good.
But your teeth.
Look Nick,
peep,
peep it.
I went to a dentist seven years ago that dentist fucked up and goes,
oh my God was this time.
Saw a dentist.
I went probably 10 years ago,
bitch.
She goes,
Yo,
you have genetically gifted teeth.
You some of the best I've ever seen.
I like,
cool.
See you never,
and your gums are good,
haunted and universal.
Never philosophy ever.
Never.
I drink,
sold his home every night.
Pulled pork.
No problem.
Oh,
I drink coffee like a motherfucker.
This is my six cup of coffee a day.
My shit still kind of white.
Kind of like corn nuts when you do the whitening.
Never.
You know why my buddy did it?
Teeth like got super sensitive and we do it too much and wears off the enamel.
Yeah,
he's on a jet ski gear booth knocked out all his team.
Got The ball in half.
How often was he doing it?
A lot.
That's why you can't you every three years.
Maybe you can do it professionally,
but don't do those fucking strips,
man.
That's dangerous.
You could feel them burning.
Of course I did it.
I just did my teeth whitening about six weeks ago and it was the,
what's that it heights to actually,
the funny thing was 24 maybe 30 hours later was more sensitive than immediately
leaving there,
but you can't drink coffee.
Right?
I didn't drink coffee around all day.
No.
For a day I can't do that.
I'm out.
I tried to Wean off God for a day.
I should swear to God.
Cold sweats in the fetal position on the ground sweat.
How much are you drinking a day?
Six.
Seven carboy hydrating enough water colors.
Your p Eau Claire.
Yeah.
So you really balance out your coffee.
I drink fluids and non stop and your teeth look great.
Thanks man.
I still want veneers.
You want to do,
you should say,
what about the,
that water pick you were thinking about using that or anything?
I don't feel like there's any meat to,
well yeah,
she said you're like genetically gifted.
So when she told me that was the same,
I'll have great teeth.
Uh,
mom pops,
my mom's little yellow.
Not going to lie my mom's teeth or your moms.
What?
60 something?
My mom's teeth look like corn nuts.
Yeah.
That's terrible.
I know dad is older.
My that's straight.
My brother had braces for about eight years.
She brought an athlete to know computer guy,
computer engineer,
smart.
I would suggest where eventually you're going to,
how old are you now?
34 yet to start flossing.
Just for your health,
for your second son.
Try it.
You just to try it.
Once you start,
it's very hard to,
to not do it.
It does feel good.
When did you start doing it?
Feels so much better.
What if I got veneers and stuff?
They'll flog.
Yes.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It doesn't,
it doesn't exempt you from hygiene.
Isn't it?
Like,
uh,
like uh,
basically like a windshield on your car.
It's terrible.
No,
it's painful and it takes a long time.
I'm not going to lie.
They shaved down your real teeth.
They,
then they cover it with the fake teeth of veneer.
It's a very,
it's an ordeal.
Don't do it unless I had to because I knocked out half a one.
What's a kit now?
I was on the rings.
That was the,
Oh,
so you've had veneers for Greg?
My whole life I've had to get fake teeth.
Oh.
Cause I knocked out half of this one as a kid.
It's like a playground accident.
Nothing really.
I'm not that tough guys.
Uh,
we got an email cause too much work.
So much work.
So it's like a grand a tooth to right,
but it's your teeth.
We just spend the money here.
Here's you go.
You guys are all about teeth health for calm my
teeth police.
This is,
yeah,
you don't take care of your teeth.
You're Outta here man.
Detectives take polices out here Bro.
You got yellow teeth.
You out.
Oh God.
Your Mommy's.
I love the podcast and have a quick question for you to ponder upon.
Since every other body fluid has it.
Diff,
definite smell.
Do boogers and snot have a set as well?
Yes.
Have we become so accustomed to this set that our brains just ignores it?
Mommy jeans.
Horrible sneezed.
Maybe wonder about this,
keeping it high and tight.
Loose Soup and dad.
Boners Dan.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think,
do you ever take one out and then smell it?
No.
Does that discussing now,
but I know I smell like my kids breath when he's got a cold and you know that
that's the smell of snob.
Yeah.
It's not smell does not smell.
I think there's definite smells,
everything,
but everything that's in your nose is not going to smell to you,
obviously,
because you can get brain gets used to it so that you can function.
Yeah.
Otherwise you'd be just completely distracted by that smell.
Like,
like La,
if you leave la for awhile,
they come back,
smells funky.
But to us this is normal.
I like,
I don't like this.
Whatever you're playing
boredom.
I Dunno.
Horse.
Somebody said it.
Oh.
Someone's going
or
someone's getting murdered.
No video or porno.
It's messy.
That's Christina Sneeze on the show.
Get upset.
A lot of people.
All right.
We gotta get going on.
This was a lot of fun.
Thanks for coming on the show.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
So keeping your camera,
you guys,
but then break your fucking arm when I get out of this.
No,
no,
please.
God.
No Man.
Anything but my arm.
Um,
anything.
Wait,
a working people see you,
Brendan,
just so they know I'm in.
And thank you Justin.
Ed Brooke.
I'm in San Francisco the same night you're in Oakland.
Oh,
town Thursday.
This Thursday.
I'm in San Francisco cobb's.
He's like 20 tickets left.
He brought jd.com for tickets and then the following Friday I'm at the laugh
factory in Long Beach.
Oh,
that's great.
[inaudible] k.com he's got very popular podcasts.
More than one.
He's got the fire of the kid with very long and thick.
Dick Bryan Cannon.
We learned it.
We've had on this show and then he also has a big brown breakdown.
Was that,
that's all fight stuff,
I'm assuming.
Nah,
y'all fight boxing.
All right.
What's going to happen?
Wait isn't a triple g Kanellis again.
What do you think's gonna Happen?
I think it's going to be a good fights.
I need to be the fight of the age is like,
people think,
I think the big knock for,
I mean that I've heard from a lot of people,
I've watched both those guys fight a good number of times is that people have
not triple g's competition.
They're like,
he's got correct hammer hands.
Correct.
But it's like a bunch of bumps.
It's like,
you know,
I won't say bummed.
I met Danny is a tough customer
and you know,
some people thought he'd beat him,
but in Danny Jacobs,
bigger guy.
But um,
again,
I,
I think it's,
we are really good fight.
I think Canelo winds in decision,
but I think most of the public things triple g wins the fight.
Then you see him in a rematch and the rematch will be the barn burner.
Okay.
But it,
it's a great five best fire.
Right?
Ah,
man,
I can't,
last time we had this ghetto fight.
It's been a long time.
Yeah,
he really does throw some fucking,
both of them are world worldclass 49 and one or some shit like that.
42 and one one s whatever.
He liked boxing.
That's a good one.
It's a good one to watch that spark to match match up in a long time.
All right.
This Saturday.
Yeah.
Don't forget.
Check out Brennan Shop.
Check out.
Uh,
October 10th.
Mark your calendars.
Mark Your Queue.
[inaudible] mother inferior on net.
I should also note that I'm going by Christina p now,
so you don't have to type in the whole fucking horrible last name.
She was Christina p Jessica CNP.
Brow mother,
like pretend it's called mother inferior,
and you can search for it this Friday and queue it up on your list.
So yeah,
we're very excited.
Very excited
or move.
All right,
bye guys.
Oh,
fun.
shaggy.
Head back.
No [inaudible] back.
Of course.
Can
your ass
you.
That's a good thing.
Low,
fast
fuck by a horse.
Okay.
Low fuss.
A Shagan that.
Yeah,
that sort of thing.
Low phos.
Oh sure.
I get that.
[inaudible] again.
That
low fives I shall get back,
back,
back.
Get fucked by a horse car.
Just like a thing.
It's fucked.
Cool.